[Music]
jurassic world
dominion experience a special extended
preview only on f9 and imax
we are still about a year away from the
release of jurassic world dominion but
to the delight of many fans there's some
exciting news about the third part of
the series
the first news involves a new image
shared by director colin trevorrow
on it can be seen as small feathered
dinosaur which seems to be making a mess
of the remains of a larger one
after many fans wondered about his
species trevorrow announced the
scientific name of the creature
namely moro's intrepidus the small
detail with the feathers is also
deliberately staged in such a way
after all some scientific studies show
that dinosaurs were at least partially
covered with feathers
the leading paleontologists are still
not quite in agreement about the
feathers but nonetheless it is great to
see that scientific findings are dealt
with in the movie
in addition there was already a first
official movie poster to admire
besides the mosquito which is very
important for the franchise you can also
see a preview of an
exclusive offer from universal if you go
to watch the new fast and furious 9
in an imax theater you will get to see a
5 minute preview of jurassic world in
advance
this snippet also reveals that the
ending of jurassic world fallen kingdom
was set about 4 years before the new
part
a lot seems to have happened in this
rather short time jump as the
dinosaurs appear to be slowly but surely
reconquering the planet
we are looking forward to more news
about jurassic world dominion
and especially to the release on june
10th 2022
[Music]
you